there are times when the cumin touches
bit inconvenient
that's up I'm on my way I'll be about 10
minutes morning just as well then but
it's becoming increasingly unnecessary
let's turn on the light say hello to
point grab we are using a computer
vision algorithm to analyze the body
language of the user so we're using just
a simple 2d cameras and it actually
analyze the body and the movement and
recognize some shapes like hands and
when you put the finger on your lips you
can control the volume make it higher
you can switch between channels just by
waving your hands and then select the
next channel that you want to watch you
can mute the volume zoom in or zoom out
you can rotate the picture if you really
like point grab has signed up samsung
Lenovo and Fujitsu to name but three
it's already profitable but its
ambitions go way beyond the living room
everything that is plugged into any
power source the points which can be
added to it and you can control it from
several ways you can turn it on and off
but you can also deeming the lights or
changing the fan levels it's thirsty
work getting to grips with this
newfangled technology a drink was needed
something fruity we know right now I've
got fruit all over my hands right so I
don't want to be touching my touch
screen I can change things just I could
why just go my god yeah well if I'm
watching a recipe or something i can
scroll down and everything so this is
ready for someone very lazy who can't
even be bothered
passing on a blender thing that we
didn't solve is someone that you will
point at it I mean somebody will draw
for you yeah rope and you want to bring
you the the drinks to the table and if
you don't have anyone to take a picture
of that special moment this point grabs
iphone app called Tammy selfies will
never be the same again and it got chem
Bloomberg hod hasharon Israel